ok allora buonasera mi presento io mi
chiamo paola e sono un insegnante come è
stato detto di una scuola romana e mi
piace molto il mio lavoro e mi
appassiona terribilmente e credo
fortemente nell'importanza del gioco
nell'apprendimento
questa è una frase di gianni rodari che
io ho praticamente fatta mia nel mio
modo di insegnare gianni rodari diceva
vale la pena che un bambino impari
piangendo quello che può imparare
ridendo e adesso in periodo di star wars
a questa immagine mi sembrava
appropriata e uno di loro dice ma perché
da altra pensa che noi impariamo di più
se siamo seduti tutto il giorno
e veniamo a quello che faccio che cosa
faccio come insegnante io nella mia
scuola in segno facendo lingua cinese
che è la cosa che mi caratterizza di più
anche forse il motivo più forte per cui
mi trovo qui perché non ci sono altre
scuole in italia dove si insegna cinese
ai bambini con la particolarità che
addirittura per questi bambini
il cinese è una materia che va
nella scheda di valutazione una cosa che
adesso sta avvenendo soltanto in alcuni
licei
poi tra le tante cose che faccio mi
piace la tecnologia in uno sproposito mi
piace e non sono l'insegnante di
tecnologia matricola tecnologia in modo
trasversale in tutte quante le mie
lezioni
poi tra le altre cose la creatività
ovviamente qualsiasi cosa faccio avviene
in modo creativo e poi mi piace molto la
robotica
siccome io robot tra didattica adesso
hanno ancora un costo eccessivo per me
ne ho comprato uno piccoli nomi sono
anche montata un mio robot con il
cacciavite e i cavi e la scheda o tutto
quanto fatto da me e
e poi lo ha portato a scuola altri
bambini hanno portato i loro abbiamo
fatto le gare in corridoio con i robot e
poi i bambini della mia classe o anno
l'ho detto sono insegnante in una terza
primaria sanno costruire la realtà
aumentata sui loro disegni proprio in
quest'ultimo periodo stiamo realizzando
un museo dei dinosauri in realtà
aumentata e poi sanno si sono
appassionati agli ologrammi e abbiamo ci
siamo aiutati grazie a dei video su
youtube è però sono anche capaci di
mettere loro all'interno di una piramide
trasparente e vedersi quindi in versione
ologramma e poi la didattica stima che
va molto adesso se ne sente parlare e
applicare l'arte la creatività alle
materie scientifiche e poi il coating
quello che si sente resto di più la
programmazione e
da quest'anno mi sono interessata al
kolding dallo scorso anno e per farlo
ovviamente ho dovuto studiare prima io
per insegnarlo ai bambini e da
quest'anno facciamo due ore recordings
fisse a settimana e bambini la vedono
quasi come un premio fare questo coding
ogni settimana perché si divertono da
morire e soprattutto sono migliorati
tantissimo in matematica perché il
codice una cosa che funziona altrimenti
non sarebbe arrivata da noi dall'america
e importante inserito nei vostri
curricolo scolastici e questa è la mia
rappresentazione versione lego ho
partecipato proprio la settimana scorsa
un workshop per insegnanti dei lego è
stato chiesto di rappresentarmi e io mi
sono rappresentata così vedendo nel
mattone giallo nel mattone rosso le
differenze tra i bambini perché un
insegnante deve saper cogliere il meglio
di tutti quanti e il mattoncino lungo
verde è invece il ponte deve essere un
raccordo tra tutti quanti i bambini il
diamantino blu perché ogni bambino per
un insegnante è veramente prezioso come
un diamante e l'albero dietro alle
spalle per accompagnare ogni bambino
nella sua crescita e poi davanti nelle
mani una paletta simbolica per insegnare
ai bambini a raccogliere i frutti più
buoni del loro lavoro e la bacchetta
come il simbolo della creatività e della
magia dell'immaginazione
queste sono un po di attività fatte in
classe c'è la realtà aumentata
c'è il co ding giochiamo con minecraft
sicuramente se avete figli nipoti tutti
quanti giocano con minecraft oggi e ci
sono i robot quella palla luminosa che
vedete tra le teste dei bambini è un
robot quei bambini hanno cinque anni
ovviamente lo programmato io e loro lì
si sono buttati sopra la palla per
capire e vedere cosa facesse come per
che camminava se nessuno la spingeva per
che cambiava
quindi i bambini hanno anche questo
approccio di vedere la tecnologia delle
cose l'internet delle cose
nonostante abbiano solo cinque anni la
tradizione scolastica oggi purtroppo non
vede ancora molto di buon occhio il
gioco perché giocare non è una cosa
seria
ti stai divertendo quindi non stai
facendo il tuo lavoro
ci vuole sforzo sacrificio impegno devi
studiare se non fatichi non riuscirai
invece non è così assolutamente perché
il gioco è un'attività molto seria
gestito a dire un bambino che lui non
sta giocando seriamente vi
rimprovererebbe senz'altro il gioco è
complicato il gioco è difficile per loro
e non
non bastava giocare perché ci sia
apprendimento perché il gioco non si
deve improvvisare c'è apprendimento
quando il gioco è organizzato quando il
gioco è preparato il ruolo tradizionale
del docente in classe sta cambiando in
questa attività
stavamo imparando i nomi delle parti del
corpo in cinese e abbiamo giocato
facendo una sorta di tuca tuca
praticamente di lingua cinese
il futuro per quanto riguarda la lingua
cinese
io ho imparato il cinese all'università
in modo molto tradizionale e anche molto
molto faticoso perché la lingua cinese
si può parlare a seconda di quanti
ideogrammi ha imparato a memoria nel tuo
percorso di studi perché non è una
lingua alfabetica e
l'unico modo che avevo per imparare
questi due grammi era fare pagine e
pagine e pagine di ideogrammi come le
stecchette di una volta all'asilo
oggi grazie ai supporti tecnologici è
tutto cambiato perché la tecnologia
aiuta molto nell'apprendimento
questi sono due bambini di scuola
primaria di prima elementare stanno
imparando il cinese grazie alla i pad
la tecnologia cattura l'interesse del
bambino e permette anche di apprendere
la lingua ma soprattutto di riproporla
in modo creativo
questo è una piramide dell'insegnamento
tradizionale della lingua cinese prima
dell'introduzione della tecnologia
bisognava ricordare faticosissimo
bisognava capire applicare analizzare
valutare e so solo dopo aver scalato
tutta questa piramide si arrivava alla
creazione un percorso molto lungo e
faticoso
oggi invece imparare cinese può essere
diverso perché viene ridotto molto
questo scoglio della della lingua
dell'ideogramma la tecnologia aiuta gli
alunni nel produrre elaborati originali
che gli permettono di dimostrare quanto
hanno appreso loro apprendono il cinese
attraverso delle delle applicazioni
ma queste applicazioni hanno anche una
sezione che permette loro di rielaborare
e quindi di produrre dei contenuti
autonomi e originali e quindi fanno
esercizio scoprono perché immaginate un
bambino di 5 6 anni che scopre la
meraviglia della lingua cinese e passano
alla creazione quindi viene molto
semplificato il percorso di studi della
lingua cinese perché utilizzare queste
applicazioni per studiare cinese
aumentano la comprensione da parte degli
alunni
aumenta la motivazione perché stiamo
usando un ipad stiamo usando
applicazioni perché con la tecnologia
siamo praticamente parlando il loro
linguaggio e aumenta le abilità nello
studio perché saper usare
un ipad per studiare presuppone comunque
sia delle competenze quindi poi questo
ti aiuterà anche nello studio di altre
discipline e favorisce il raggiungimento
di un obiettivo più elevato nei test che
si effettuano nei test di gruppo questi
sono dei bambini che stanno realizzando
un loro mini dizionario di lingua cinese
senza abbandonare la carta
noi utilizziamo l'ipad sui banchi ci
sono gli ipad ma sanno anche ritagliando
incollando cartoncini quindi va bene
utilizzare il digitale ma ovviamente non
si abbandona la la parte manuale la
parte pratica questo è un bambino cinque
anni e in quel momento chiedere a lui
indicami fuoco
lui sa scegliere l'ideogramma corretto e
ha solo cinque anni e queste sono altre
immagini di bambini che riguardano anche
la parte della cultura perché ovviamente
insegnare cinese è importante anche per
permettere l'accoglienza anche degli
studenti cinesi che sono sempre più
numerosi nelle nostre classi di bambini
italiani
quindi c'è anche maggiore interazione
fra di loro
quando i bambini sono così piccoli
ovviamente si spinge molto
sull'accettazione di una cultura diversa
sulla scoperta di una cultura diversa
così così antica così affascinante e
facciamo appunto anche tante attività
manuali che riguardano la cultura cinese
e i bambini scrivono anche con il
pennello questo lo abbiamo visto anche
prima e utilizziamo l'ipad per scrivere
nel modo corretto i caratteri cinesi
perché non basta saperli scrivere quindi
riprodurli esattamente come li vediamo
ma c'è anche un giusto ordine di
scrittura e ci sono numerose le
applicazioni che fanno vedere tutto
quanto questo processo e bruno munari ci
ha detto quando qualcuno dice questo lo
so fare anch'io
vuol dire che lo sa rifare altrimenti lo
avrebbe fatto prima un bambino un giorno
a scuola non ha detto maestra ho
costruito una macchina che cammina gli
ho detto bellissimo riccardo dove li
porta me la scuola ha portato questo e
mi ha anche detto maestra adesso smonto
il telecomando della playstation due
cavetti e domani cammina quindi è per me
io avevo gli occhi a forma di cuoricino
praticamente perché prima è fantastico
perché nella sua creatività nella sua
immaginazione
lui ha anche disposto le batterie in un
certo modo quindi probabilmente anche
calcolato dei pesi per far camminare
questa questa sua macchina e mi piace mi
piace pensare che questi bambini che
oggi stanno applicando tutte queste
queste
tecniche particolari facciamo così tante
cose un domani possano essere veramente
quelli che costruiranno un qualcosa che
potrà salvare l'umanità che potrà
guarire da qualche malattia delle cose
veramente importanti
e questa è la mia classe in una foto
panoramica perché in realtà è molto più
piccola di quel che sembra
e sono bambini molto molto aperti molto
allegri e stanno lavorando lavorando in
maniera autonoma si alzano si muovono
all'interno della classe sono proprio
una classe in fermento e queste sono
altre attività che stiamo facendo in
classe prendono notizie dagli ipad e
riportano lì a terra stanno disegnando e
colorando il nostro museo dei dinosauri
stanno facendo tantissime tantissime
cose
e una cosa che ci tengo a dire che la
mia formazione è avvenuta sia a livello
universitario
però tutte queste cose io le ho imparate
da da maestre di scuola pubblica perché
su facebook ci sono diversi gruppi e
comunità di insegnanti che interagiscono
e ognuno mette il buono il bello che sta
facendo perché spesso è molto più facile
distruggere la scuola piuttosto che
esaltare la meraviglia le persone
veramente speciali che ci stanno
mettendo davvero anima e corpo perché la
scuola migliori perché credono nel
futuro dei bambini e la creatività non
può svilupparsi sotto controllo per
questo nella mia classe cioè tutto quel
fermento e regole che vengono dettate
dall'alto dall'insegnante necessita di
autonomia ed apprendimento non lineare
utilizziamo la tecnologia però come
vedete quando vanno in giardino fanno la
conta perché deve iniziare il gioco
quella conta toccandosi le scarpe quindi
in realtà non
perché spesso mi viene detto ha però
tutta questa tecnologia e questi ipad e
bambini fa male non è assolutamente vero
imparano un sacco di cose le sanno
applicare perché sanno fare veramente
tanto in cui sono arrivata qui ad arezzo
ieri parlando con alcune persone ho
detto le cose che facciamo ci sono
persone tecniche che mi hanno detto
anche io faccio questo e questi bambini
hanno otto anni e stanno sviluppando
delle competenze che sicuramente saranno
loro utili un domani nel lavoro e
utilizziamo appunto la creatività questa
è una immagine di quando l'anno scorso
abbiamo imparato l'orologio e si sono
divertiti da morire
con questo orologio realizzato a terra
semplicemente con lo scotch scarta e
questa è la rappresentazione dei bambini
di come loro vedono la scuola del futuro
abbiamo fatto un mini l'eco serious
player è la cosa che mi ha colpito è che
i bambini hanno creato all'interno della
scuola degli angoli di apprendimento
c'era il luogo dove si poteva fare in
realtà aumentata
il luogo dove si poteva studiare i
dinosauri con i loro scheletri e li ho
chiesto sì vabbè minima le stanze le
aule dove stanno e loro mi hanno
risposto a maestra ma noi già impariamo
così che ci facciamo con l'aula e la
gamification è un termine che sta
andando adesso si sta sentendo molto
e a fine febbraio ho partecipato ad un
convegno di insegnanti e dirigenti
italiani dove la scuola sta cercando di
di affrontare questo tema appunto per
l'importanza del gioco e sono stati
posti ai partecipanti i sette principi
del gioco tutti partecipano a prendere
sembra un gioco tutto è interconnesso si
impara facendo il fallimento e
riformulato con iterazione il feedback
immediato la sfida è costante tutto
questo rende ovviamente una lezione che
avviene attraverso il gioco estremamente
coinvolgente il gioco appunto rende
l'apprendimento irresistibile e confuso
ci ha detto se ascolto dimentico se vedo
ricordo se faccio capire
grazie